[Applause]
baby Sussex is do almost any day and we
have questions is it a boy or a girl and
what are Megan and Harry going to name
it here's a look at some solid option
what's in a name
royal tradition dictates a child have at
least one name that comes from royal
lineage which kind of limits the options
Prince William and Kate Middleton
followed tradition with their three kids
George pays homage to Queen Elizabeth's
father King George the six Charlotte's
middle names are Elizabeth and Diana so
no question about where those came from
and Louis pays tribute to Prince
Philip's late uncle Lord Louis
Mountbatten he also shares a middle name
with Grandpa
Prince Charles but given that Harry and
Megan's child will fall seventh in line
to the throne they'll probably have more
leeway when picking a moniker and no
prince or princess title for their royal
babe unless the Queen steps in to make
that change
almost immediately after Megan's
pregnancy reveal oddsmakers hit the
ground running
we also generally couldn't think of a
better place to announce the upcoming
baby boy or go betting site Ladbrokes
tweeted their best guesses with Queen
Victoria's name topping the list for
girls and her husband Albert's moniker
is the number one pick for boys but fair
on the other hand has Diana topping
their list and we'd have to agree we
will do everything we can to make sure
that she's never forgotten from Harry's
charity work to Megan's frequent fashion
nods and the incorporation of her
favorite things into their wedding day
the Sussex duo works hard to keep Ty's
legacy alive I hope that just once again
everything we do privately and
unofficially that it makes her proud
giving their firstborn her name would be
the ultimate nod but the late princess
isn't the only parent in the mix
while their odds aren't as great Charles
and Georgia also made that fairs list
alice is another bookie favorite it's
also the name of Queen Elizabeth and and
Prince Philip's mom but there's also a
good chance Harry and Megan will veer
away from traditional names and go
off-script she's a new trip submits a
new chapter right according to our royal
sorest the couple is determined to give
their child as normal and upbringing as
possible so a name popular amongst us
commoners wouldn't be off-brand
parenting website baby Center has Sophia
Olivia Emma Ava and Isabella as the most
popular girl named last year while
Jackson Liam Noah Aiden and Caden topped
the list for boys the truth is we don't
really have very long to wait to find
out now there are two names we'd guess
are definitely out Thomas and Samantha
from Megan's dad and half-sister they've
been causing problems since of the very
start what do you think Megan and Harry
will name their first child tell us in
the comments
[Music]